. So Rudy Giuliani is not
the only whacked out lawyer
representing Donald Trump in his futile attempts
to overturn the results of the 2020 election,
which Joe Biden won. There's this other lawyer
named Sydney Powell. Now, last week, when I noted
Sydney Powell seems absolutely out of her mind
during that bizarre press conference at which
Rudy Giuliani's face melted. Some people wrote to
me and said, David, you know, it's kind of sounds
like you're making fun of Sidney Powles accent.
I guess she's Southern. That's not what it was
with any accent. The things Sidney Powell was
saying make no sense. She suggested last week
that there was a conspiracy to steal the
election from Donald Trump by Joe Biden
involving this is not a joke. Venezuela and Cuba,
the long dead Hugo Chavez and Nicolas Maduro,
George Soros and Tifa, some guy named Eric
Kumah and the Clinton Foundation, she seemed
completely out of her mind. We now have more
video evidence that she is indeed very sick. She
was interviewed on Newsmax TV over the weekend.
Newsmax, is this even crazier alternative to Fox
News that Donald Trump has been recommending along
with on and she claimed that they will be making a
biblical filing about voter fraud against
Donald Trump. She says the filings are coming
and they will be biblical. What does that mean?
I have no idea. See if you can figure it out.
You know, I know you say you want to do your
arguing in court. You are an attorney. You're
not a press secretary. But you all did have
a press conference last week. Jordan Sekulow
said that there's going to be a filing soon
in Georgia that would be explosive. Can you
tell us anything? Can you make some news with us
here tonight? Tell us anything new that you're
going to present in that filing in Georgia?
Well, I can't say that yet, but hopefully
this week we will we will get it ready to file
city. What's in it will it will be biblical
biblical guys.
We have to be allowed to call this what it is.
These are delusions. This is mental illness.
We can't say, well, because she's a Christian,
this is not mental illness. A biblical filing
about fraud in a court of law. Guys, please.
This is where, you know, if this were not Trump's
lawyer and this were not a Christian, if they said
something equivalent to this, you would be
looking at a 72 hour psych hold for an individual
like this. She also said that there are likely
thousands of people involved in the conspiracy.
I mean, how big of a you know, if if
this happened, how big of a conspiracy,
how many people would have had to
have been in on something like this?
Oh, gosh. Probably thousands, including the
people running the machines at each of the polling
polling centers. We know, for example, that one
of the higher ups of Dominion went to Detroit the
night of the election to handle things himself.
And we also have evidence that there were any
number of DPN lines open to the Internet
for foreign actors to be meddling in it.
Yeah, those thousands of people in on it.
One of the things we know from experience
is that when there are more than a handful of
people involved, you can't cover it up. And yet we
had the Texas governor offering a million dollars
as a reward for proof of voter fraud. Nobody's
been able to collect the million dollars they're
sworn. Affidavits keep getting dismissed in court.
Courts keep finding there's no merit to any of
these claims. If thousands of people are involved,
there would be widespread, undeniable proof.
You can't cover it up if thousands of people are
involved. And then Sydney Powell goes back into
the stuff about Venezuela, Venezuelan witnesses.
Has anybody given you an explanation that that
as to why they had to turn the machines off?
You talk about how the machine that turned our key
ah witness from Venezuela who saw it all created
and how it worked so that he knew as soon as the
machines were turned off and those key states,
it was because we, the people in voting Trump
and voting for Trump in a landslide election
had essentially broken the algorithm that
had been preprogrammed into the machine.
So they had to stop counting in those days.
Did you hear that one? People voted for Trump
so overwhelmingly that it broke the machine
algorithms, whatever that means. She says
Trump lost by six million and she's saying Trump
won by so much that it broke the machines. This
is a very sick person and sadly, people fall
for it and it has even become too much for
the Trump campaign. They put out a statement
yesterday after this interview came out saying
that Sydney Powell is practicing law on her own.
She's not part of Donald Trump's legal team. She's
not a Trump lawyer. She's essentially been fired
because up until yesterday, she did appear to be
all of those things. Donald Trump even previously
tweeted about her that he has the best lawyers and
representatives, including Sydney Powell, which
we have up on the screen for you. It's just a
hilarious comedy of errors. The Trump campaign now
distancing from this lunatic woman as quickly as
they can, but people fall for it. I got a very
distressing email over the weekend from a viewer
who said, David, my mom completely fell for that
press conference. The press conference you and I
likely watched. And we see Rudy Giuliani's hair
dye melting and Sidney Powell blaming Antifa and
George Soros and and Venezuela for stealing the
election. And we recognize these are ill people.
This viewer's mom fell for it and thought
that Sidney Powell is just a brilliant lawyer
doing God's work. And this viewer spent hours
convincing his mom that that's not the case.
It's really scary stuff. And as with Trump ism
in general, the really scary part is the number
of people just falling for this nonsense hook,
line and sinker. Biblical submissions proving
voter fraud against Donald Trump, sad and scary.
We'll have more about this on our Instagram page.
We are at The David Pakman Show on
Instagram. While you're there, you can
follow me on Instagram as well at David Pakman,
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman dot com.